[Musique]
et
et comment tu vas faire avec trois
secondes à la pendule allez faut que
maxime soit malin la halle et le marlou
en une petite déco ça ferait pas de mal
donc je vous laisse
adam 6
mais oui j'ai tiré le premier père du
joueur français la déco c'était des
communes à 26 en fait il avait prévu fou
g5 et maxime lui a fait 1 dames 6 marlou
ouais mais bon t'as tour un train à
cavaillon oui ça copions bien non ils
savent pas la foulée 6 oui non oui j'ai
parlé trop vite mais je me comprends
ouais ben terre on s'est compris en fait
j'ai vu au moment où il a joué oui oui
même
we have sur vos proches c'est tout il ya
le petit fauve et si ce qui fait plaisir
mais là il ya pas que anja g4 qui prend
quasiment le pion donc il le sac
vraiment c'est chaud bouillant etienne a
laissé cette même étant il a bien fait
de prendre le pion je pense au moins il
part plus à laisser encore une
forteresse malheureusement à me veut il
veut monter avec laurent f6 ou le marlou
une forteresse ah oui aya parois des
quatre mesdames mt 8
au droit common leroy le plan de marloux
un déca 3e 5 3 des 6 3 e cette dame a
fui 3 3 et 6 mais cet homme est un génie
when i was set quand même je pense et
d'amalfi trois existants mais c'est
l'extraordinaire extraordinaire mon
amour ou omet alors la has qui lui a mis
extraordinaire sectionnelles ça c'est
l'extraordinaire etienne bah ouais là
vous avez vous venez de vivre un moment
de blitz spectaculaire le plan qu'il a
trouvé quoi finale elle a quand même
l'air tellement gagnante que je vois pas
comment ils jouent pas d'un pro f 4 mois
je serai dames 1re caté g4 en fait juste
vêtements ouais ou d'un projet 4 ou d'un
premier 4 fléchi mais le joueur tour 8
d'abord qu'il veut quand même être le
rang à 7 à roy c'est cette du coup à
temps il va pas juste se faire mater
après l'âme 17
qu'est-ce qui fait magnus seimat en
trois sets c'était
spectaculaire ça fait 3 2 pour le joueur
français qui nie a fini comme en tout
cas qu'il est vite poussé quatre
magnifiques
c'est super ça coco et g4 maintenant
menace d'orage cinq tours prince est
imparable
ouais aux minima amy a minima a minima
fais nous un petit coup au 6e tour f6
maintenant au moins on en parle plus à
bas la foudre en est on des quatre fonds
pranger 6e tour des grottes ma'afu
pranger ici peu fou et quatre au kef où
pranger 6e games com
ouais mais tour h5 et tour des quatre et
tout reproche cette tourelle et chant
non y'a pas vous tragique dont g5 et
yappa tour g6 marlou ted ballou ted il
joue plus vite
bah c'est une fusée c'est frais c'est
simplement une fusée et prendrait jamais
demandé il ya quoi
sk 4 way f
attends attends attends etienne f ça ou
ils empêchent d'alger 2 comme ça ouais
c'est le bouillant y tire ça avec 10
secondes
wade à metz troyes ils essaient bien
joué leur cible le magnifique à et
cavaliers belges d'amd smyczek barbu
l'aide d'ambulances vite vite vite vite
etienne il va faire quoi dames 1 dames
ici et elle est proche mais oui mais oui
etienne mais bien sûr qui va la chercher
mais bien sûr qu'il va la chercher il
avait happé la baie la paix à la dame g6
impressionnant où elle fait mal ça là il
pourra dire celui-là il fait plaisir aux
elle fait plaisir celle là il te g600
spectaculaire j'envoie la perruque
j'envoyais ouais mais jean brajon voix
mais on en a besoin bas qui est
magnifique
bah ouais technique mais vraiment au
poil 1la de maxime il faut encore la
gagner mais alors il a super bien joué
qu'à venise de 4-3 aux deux imagine pied
tant soit peu un phare
c'est sous permettent tour trois échecs
roi is it au registre
ah c'est pas encore game média minois et
ses tours f3 c'était ok tout répéter ses
gammes
c'est comme ça oui ces dames et
attaquera mais c'est game c'est bien la
game
ouais c'est chaud mais ça gagne la bnp
ont passé côté magnus
il faut pas crier victoire trop tôt tout
rage de bien jouer pour jauger de
wallonie alors attends ouais j'ai 83 ses
gammes
c'est gavray et magnus manuscrits magnus
qui s'effondre c'est bon donc et plus
fin ok allez à l'austin risque c'est la
déco tout rêve doit il est pas moins
autour f2 bien jouer non non il est pas
moins bien il n'est pas moins bien mais
on était très proche de complètement
gagnant pourrait faire venir jouer aussi
tour en f1 cavaliers pranger 3 il va
faire quoi 5à il va envoyer le pion h au
c'est terrible il veut jouer fois six
îles actifs ou incroyable ce coup h5
incroyable ça fallait le voir ont la
pression qui met avec ce coup franc
si cela est vrai mais attend il ya la
dame qui revient qu'il y avait des
saints qui a [ __ ] en dessin qui
défiant ya passé trois recettes reculent
fillon prend qui s'est cassé chaud
bref j'aime moins trois pions remplacés
casse est ce que c'est que peut-être
qu'ils gagnent droit des trois qui
avaient des deux rois des deux fous
prendre trois oui il faut prendre trois
naturels aussi y va il peut pas faire
d'abord un cavalier c'est qu'alors on
avait trop abandon avant dont +4 etienne
on va au bout là ouais mais ça va ça va
ça va être un rayon de 5 qui tient la
position et la connexion une en
connexion il n'y a pas besoin n'y a pas
besoin de ça le joueur français qui est
assez fort étienne pour pour l'écraser
sont des collections qui est qu'ils
arrivent angers 6
il a l'air de se présenter il ya dame
prend 2,6 qui tombe royale x 600 prises
est ce qu'il ya un cavalier 3e cette
dame prend 2,7 pour prendre cette allée
ya la qualité plus comme contre hikaru
il ya quelques il ya quelques jours
etienne
cette fois çi pour il faut la gagner
ayyash 4 pour pour éviter tous les
problèmes tour à 7 c'est bien joué
fou prend ses quatre tours points à 5
ouais c'est chaud elle est complètement
gagnante mais c'est irrationnel et les
tombes
gagner c'est gagner tienne c'est gagné
un extra ordinaire et extraordinaire
etienne
il a gagné il est gagné le match dans la
dernière partie gagner des secondes ici
[Musique]